nous sommes très heureux de vous saluer
de vous accueillir au kremlin vous
monsieur le président de la république
emmanuel écrit macron je considère comme
symbolique que notre rencontre ait lieu
précisément le 7 février
cette journée ici et heure de moscou se
termine mais c'est quand même justement
il ya trente ans que le document
fondamental
d'établissement de relations
diplomatiques entre nos deux pays a été
signé c'est un document très important
qui a lancé le fondement des relations
de partenariat et de respect mutuel de
coopération entre nos pays et
aujourd'hui notre discussion avec
monsieur macron
conformons à la tradition on était très
détaillé et utile
nous comprenons évidemment que monsieur
le président est venu en russie d'abord
pour parler de la thématique d'actualité
de la sécurité européenne et mondiale
et nos pays comme membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu ont une
responsabilité spéciale à cet égard
d'autre part la france assure
actuellement la présidence du conseil
européen et au cours de nos discussions
nous avons procédé à un échange de vues
sur
les propositions russes adressé à la
russie à l'otan visant à assurer à
donner des garanties
juridiquement contraignantes en matière
de sécurité dans lesquelles il ya trois
points importants la non extension de
l'otan à l'est
la l'arrêt de déploiement d'armes à
portée intermédiaire et le retour à
l'état de
1997 qui était donc l'année l'an de
laquelle a été signé l'acte fondamental
de nos accords et tout cela
les souhaits russes n'ont pas été
respectez n'ont pas été satisfaites dans
la réponse donnée le 26 janvier par nos
partenaires occidentaux qui se référer
au fait que chaque pays a le droit de
choisir librement ses alliances
militaires pour assurer sa sécurité
et d'ailleurs nous n'avons jamais
contesté ce droit ce principe mais il
n'y a pas non plus d'obligation
d'accepter tous les pays dans l'alliance
c'est la politique de la porte ouverte
nous avons parlé de cela avec beaucoup
de partenaires et aujourd'hui avec
monsieur le président donc la politique
de portes ouvertes est
suffisamment libre
et je pense que l'interprétation qui en
est faite par les etats-unis et par
d'autres pays peut être diverses en
matière de du caractère indivisible de
la sécurité donc encore une fois ce
principe qui est important pour nous
c'est que chaque pays peut assurer sa
sécurité à condition de ne pas menacer
celle d'autres pays
donc cette politique de la porte ouverte
comme j'ai dit et je le rappeler
plusieurs fois et dans cette salle
récemment notamment lors de ma rencontre
avec la presse lors de la visite du
premier ministre hongrois viktor orban
et le
l'acte fondateur de signiant 49 de
l'otan ou dit justement l'article 10 dit
que on peut inviter d'autres pays
européens de l'alliance et ce sont des
pays qui peuvent apporter une
contribution à la sécurité européenne
mais cela ne signifie pas que comme je
les dis
l'alliance est obligé d'accepter
d'autres mondes enfin bon je voulais
notez aussi que la russie
veut toujours
voudrait justement conserver qu'on se
continuer à considérer que c'est une
alliance défensive est-ce dans quelle
mesure cela correspond à la réalité
notre expérience et l'expérience de
beaucoup de détails montrent que
par exemple l'irak la libye
l'afghanistan
et les autres grosses opérations qui ont
été faites à belgrade sans
sanctions du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu
tout cela ce sont des opérations
qui ne font pas partie de ce que peut
apporter une
organisation pacifique d'autre part ne
ne pouvons pas
passer outre
la
définition stratégique donné par l'otan
en 2019 dans laquelle l'otan est désigné
comme menace et comme adversaire
et dans cette infrastructure militaire
qui se rapproche de nos frontières
elle se considère considère qu'elle a le
droit de nous donner des leçons de nous
dire où placer nos troupes ou faire des
manoeuvres et c est encore une fois je
dis que
aujourd'hui il ya cette
présence qui est considéré aujourd'hui
comme une menace pour le cred mais il ya
d'autres pays les pays baltes d'autres
pays voisins sur quelle base ils
abritent des troupes de l'otan je ne
sais pas c'est pas mais enfin tout cela
fait que ça une politique assez étrange
vis-à-vis de la russie et les pays
continuent les autres pays occidentaux
continuent à augmenter la puissance
militaire de l'ukraine a participé à sa
formation à sa modernisation et en
envoyant des instructeurs des
spécialistes nous en avons parlé tout
cela évidemment vrai que monsieur
le président pendant plusieurs heures
pendant presque six heures en fait est
bien en temps bien évidemment j'ai
attiré l'attention de monsieur président
sur la réticence des autorités de kiev
de respecter leurs obligations deux
accords de minsk et notamment et qui
avait été confirmée à paris et à berlin
aujourd'hui c'est clair que les
autorités de kiev cherche aujourd'hui à
saboter ses accords de minsk sur des
questions importantes comme la la
réforme constitutionnelle l'aministie
le statut particulier de dans des bars
et la législation russe ukrainienne n'a
toujours pas
un n'a pas encore officialisé la formule
dit steinmeier
qui faisait que les accords de minsk
proposait donc un certain nombre de
concessions étaient proposés
et le président actuel le président
allemand actuel qui était donc le
ministre des affaires étrangères à
l'époque ces propositions n'ont pas été
respectées et aujourd'hui il n'y a
toujours pas de dialogue direct avec les
autorités de donetsk donetsk est
lougansk où
nous avons attiré l'attention du
président sur les infractions aux droits
de l'homme en ukraine l'élimination
d'opposants
les restrictions à la presse d'ailleurs
comme pour prochaine côté encore
président ukrainien je l'avais dit que
si il a des problèmes à l'avenir la
russie est prête à lui accorder l'asile
politique
il y avait beaucoup d'ironie autour de
cette question à l'époque mais
aujourd'hui je viens voudrais confirmer
ma proposition parce que malgré nos
divergences importantes sur le règlement
dans le mur dans le donbass je considère
qu'il a fait beaucoup de fautes
d'erreurs sur ce plan mais en tout cas
sa poursuite les poursuites dont il fait
l'objet en tant que
traître nationale me paraît un petit peu
exagéré et en tout cas je suis prêt à
accorder l'asile politique à monsieur
paulson co mais en tout cas on voit que
sur le plan législatif aujourd'hui en
ukraine d
obstruction sont imposés à l'égard de la
population
russophone
et les usages de la langue maternelle
est un peu bizarre aujourd'hui cela ne
correspond pas vraiment à une position
de correspondant à l'esprit des pays
européens
donc les questions de garanties sur la
sécurité en europe et le règlement
ukrainien le président
l'a dit aujourd'hui à l'intention de
discuter de tout cela avec lors de sa
rencontre demain avec les autorités
ukrainiennes nous avons abordé d'autres
problèmes internationaux et régionaux la
question autour du nagorny karabakh le
rôle positif des soldats de la paix
russes haut karabakh qui permette de
rétablir les modalités habituelles de
vie normale sur place il ya le groupe de
minsk de l'osce c'est eux aussi et dans
la résolution des problèmes économiques
humanitaires sur place monsieur le
président a rendu compte un petit peu de
ses entretiens avec
monsieur michel et les questions 1
avec le premier ministre arménien et le
président azerbaïdjanais nous avons
parlé de la question
de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien de
2015 et qui a été validé par la
résolution 22,31 du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu et
il nous sommes solidaires sur le fait
qu'il faut poursuivre les efforts
diplomatiques et
coopérer sur la base de solutions de
compromis et cela c'est parce que c'est
un document qui est important nous
sommes bien d'accord sur le fait que la
nos positions tafer proches et comme
disent les diplomates elle coince et de
nous avons aussi à attirer notre
attention sur les questions de
coopération bilatérale notamment sur le
plan économique et nous avons noté que
malgré la difficulté de la situation
liée à la pandémie coronavirus et sur
les onze premiers mois de
l'an dernier le volume de nos échanges a
augmenté de 71% et les investissements
français en russie sont de 23 milliards
de dollars et cela représente plus de
600 entreprises en russie et dans
l'ensemble nous voulons poursuivre cette
coopération tout à fait bénéfique entre
nos deux pays et dans tous les domaines
y compris sur le plan
universitaire intellectuelle et
culturelle et jeu pour finir je tiens
reprise a remercié le président pour les
efforts qu'il en a que la france
entreprend dirigé par lui pour
résoudre cette crise difficile dans nos
relations avec l'otan d'une manière
générale sur les questions de garanties
de sécurité sur le continent européen
pour assurer la stabilité et la
confiance mutuelle et s'ils trouvent une
solution pour résoudre la crise qui est
ce
déroule dans l'est ukrainien
et donc il ya un certain nombre de
problèmes pour chaque chef d'état
notamment pour un grand pays européen
mais le président a considéré qu'il
était important de venir ici en russie
pour échanger pour échanger sur la façon
de traiter ces problèmes il a proposé un
certain nombre de solutions il est
peut-être encore trop tôt pour en parler
en tout cas cela me paraît
paraît qu'il ya des
opportunités pour entreprendre des
mesures en commun
on va voir comment va se passer la
rencontre avec le président ukrainien
mais nous sommes mis d'accord sur le
fait qu'après sa visite en ukraine le
président me tiendrai au courant de ces
discussions je vous remercie pour votre
attention
sur le président je vais pas dire merci
pour votre accueil dans un moment
difficile à la fois par les contraintes
sanitaires et les tensions qui sont à
l'oeuvre sur le continent européen
et en ce jour en effet qui marque le 30e
anniversaire
de nos relations reprises nos relations
le mât ticket de cet accord bilatéral
que vous avez évoquées et je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce que vous avez
évoqué sur les relations bilatérales
entre nos deux pays parce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui conscient de la
gravité l'un et l'autre de la situation
et de la nécessité impérative dans
l'intérêt de tous de trouver le chemin
de la préservation de la paix et de la
stabilité en europe et je crois
profondément qu'il est encore temps
le dialogue
à la fois historique et stratégique que
nous avons construit ensemble au cours
des dernières années
petit aider et c'est dans ce contexte
que nous avons décidé en effet de
rencontrer aujourd'hui à moscou nous
avons eu un échange nourri
substantielle concentrait sur les
tensions actuelles et les voix de
désescalade comme les garanties de
nature à préserver la sécurité et la
stabilité sur notre continent sur le
président vous venez de rappeler ici
quelle était la vision de la russie
qu'il s'agisse de l'alliance atlantique
des intérêts de sécurité qui sont les
vôtres ou de la question ukrainienne je
crois que chacun aura vu que vous avez
une vision forte
qui parfois n'est pas moi même que sauf
des européens ou des occidentaux point
n'est besoin ici de souligner et ils
marquent très clairement des différences
de vue qu'il faut assumer et que nous
avons d'ailleurs regarder l'un et
l'autre moi je crois dans l'europe et
l'unité de l'europe je pense est un
élément fondateur est fondamentale et en
effet la politique de portes ouvertes de
l'otan a été acté en ce qu'elle est
aussi essentiel existentielle pour des
pays comme la suède ou la finlande
il serait surprenant d'ailleurs de leur
dire soudainement que l'otan change de
ligne par contre nous devons considérer
ce que vous avez exprimé avec vos mots
qui sont les incompréhensions
successives les traumatismes à coup sûr
qui se sont construits durant les trois
dernières décennies et la nécessité de
bâtir les termes nouveaux qui
permettront seule la sécurité la
stabilité dans la région mais je ne
pense pas que bâtir c'était renouveau
passe par la révision
partiale des 30 dernières années
d'accord ni de nos principes
fondamentaux né en limitant le droit de
certains européens qu'ils sont pas
partie prenante des désaccords actuels
et je pense que c'est un élément très
important
une fois cela étant posé
nous avons essayé de bâtir des éléments
de convergence pour agir utilement dans
les prochaines semaines
le premier élément c'est la nécessité de
travailler très rapidement pour éviter
toute escalade
l'accumulation des tensions en cours en
porte un risque de dégradation brutale
de l' équilibre et de la stabilité du
continent
et ne serait dans l'intérêt de personne
car ni la russie ni les européens n'ont
intérêt au désordre et à l'instabilité
dans une période où les peuples du
continent éprouvé sur le plan sanitaire
ne sait économiques ou sociaux aspirent
avant tout à la tranquillité à
l'apaisement ils relèvent donc de notre
responsabilité partagée de nous entendre
sur des mesures concrètes pour
stabiliser la situation et envisager une
désescalade nous les avons évoqué
ensemble elles devront être confirmés
dans les prochains jours et prochaines
semaines elles dépendent des
consultations qui sont en cours des
échanges avec les etats-unis l'otan des
concertations avec les européens des
échanges que j'aurai aussi demain avec
le président céline ski je veux ici dire
que le président poutine mais en tout
cas assuré de sa disponibilité à
s'engager dans cette logique et sa
volonté de maintenir ses équilibres
d'initiative et en particulier en ce qui
concerne la souveraineté l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine
les prochains jours seront déterminants
et nécessite évidemment des discussions
nourries que nous allons poursuivre
ensemble mais ça implique et j je crois
que c'était très clair dans le propos
que vient de tenir le président poutine
et et les échanges que nous avons eus
désescalade furet durable nécessite
d'avancer sur les questions de fond
c'est le deuxième grand type de sujet
sur lequel nous avons longuement discuté
qui est la volonté de travailler
ensemble sur les garanties de sécurité
qui nous permettront de construire un
nouvel ordre de sécurité de stabilité en
europe cet ordre dispose tout d'abord
d'un socle que nous avons bâti est actée
ensemble en tant qu'etat souverain
conformément aussi au principe de
continuité de la vie des états je parle
là de la russie la france mais de tous
les autres états qui sont partie
prenante à ces traités ce socle ce sont
les principes fondateurs de la sécurité
européenne
auxquels nous avons collectivement
souscrit dans la charte de paris puis
réaffirmé dans les déclarations
subséquentes de l'ouest ces droits qui
découle de la souveraineté ont été
forcés de constater violées ou battues
en brèche sur notre continent je pense
par exemple au respect de l'intégrité
territoriale des états ou non recours à
la menace ou à l'emploi de la force à
l'inviolabilité des frontières à la non
intervention dans les affaires
intérieures ou à l'exécution de bonne
foi des obligations du droit
international comme au respect des
droits de l'homme et des libertés
fondamentales
quelle que soit la lecture historique
que nous faisons des crises des
déséquilibres qui ont bousculé ces
dernières années la sécurité de notre
continent dont nous avons là aussi
longuement parlé pour être maintenu a
besoin que nous ne reproduisons pas ici
les erreurs du passé
et donc
nous avons passé plusieurs heures à -cg
aujourd'hui mais c'est aussi le field
d'un échange et de discussions reprises
ont commencé il ya plusieurs années je
mesure les malentendus qui se sont
installés les traumatismes qu'ils font
partie aussi de l'histoire des peuples
je ne mésestime pas non plus les
morsures du passé les traumatismes qui
existe chez plusieurs membres de l'union
européenne qui ont vécu un vingtième
siècle différentes celui de la france et
je crois que nous ne pouvons pas
construire ni notre présent et notre
avenir en faisant fi de cela ça n'a pas
disparu durant ces trente dernières
années
mais nous ne pouvons pas courir le
risque collectivement de voir revenir en
europe le spectre de la confrontation
des sphères d'influencé de l'instabilité
du désordre cela créerait d'autres
fractures d'autres rancoeur d'autres
menaces
il est toujours simple de commencer un
conflit beaucoup moins de savoir le
terminé de bâtir une paix durable c'est
pourquoi
je ne crois pas que nous soyons
condamnés à choisir entre deux nouvelles
règles ou l'absence de règles
c'est ce qui relève chez moi de
l'optimisme de l'eau de la volonté parce
que je sais l'attachement de la russie à
la souveraineté et aux droits qu'elle
emporte j'ai la conviction que nous
pourrons construire la sécurité et la
stabilité en europe en réaffirmant et en
respectant la kids le sc eux que nous
avons construit ensemble
mais aussi en bâtissant des solutions
nouvelles
peut-être plus innovantes
sur justement notre capacité à apporter
des garanties concrètes de sécurité nous
l'avons évoqué de manière très directe
en respectant les intérêts les éléments
de sécurité de stabilité pour tous nos
frères européens en respectant les
demandes et les garanties qui sont
posées par
notre voisin et ami russe j'ai dit au
président poutine ma préoccupation à cet
égard sur le projet de nouvelle
constitution de la biélorussie qui
propose de supprimer deux notions
fondamentales de son statut depuis 1994
et l'appel du 27 décembre dernier du
président loukachenko
sur les armes nucléaires j à cet égard
je dois le dire étaient rassurés par le
président poutine
tout cela est un point de préoccupation
car il vient accroître les
déstabilisations et donc bâtir ensemble
dans le respect de nos fondamentaux des
garanties concrètes de sécurité pour les
états membres de l'union européenne pour
les états de la région l'ukraine la
géorgie la biélorussie et pour la russie
c'est exactement l'ambition que nous
devons poursuivre nous avons
une discussion qui a permis d'enclencher
une série de propositions sur lesquelles
je crois pouvoir dire qu'il y à des
termes de convergence entre la russie et
la france vous avez vous-même commencer
des discussions avec le temps des états
unis d'amérique
il nous appartient dans les prochains
jours et les prochaines semaines de
poursuivre ces discussions concrètes
pour bâtir précisément
ces nouvelles garanties de paix et de
sécurité à cet égard les demandes de
garanties formulée de longue date par la
russie sur la limitation des
déploiements militaires la transparence
des activités militaires
conventionnelles en europe la
transparence sur la défense antimissile
et le régime de contrôle et de
limitation poste effet ni sur les
missiles de courte portée et
intermédiaires sont autant de demandes
de la russie qui correspondent
exactement aux demandes formulées par
les états européens
je ne doute pas que nous serons en
capacité d'apporter une réponse
collective
nous tous européens mais aussi allier et
américains
nous avons très récemment démontré notre
capacité à travailler ensemble
en particulier au sein du p5 qui réunit
les membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies aussi je
pense comme d'ailleurs nous l'avions
évoqué l'un et l'autre que ce format
serait aussi de nature à nous permettre
d'avancer sur ces sujets et de pouvoir
en particulier sur les questions de
maintien de la paix de sécurité là aussi
bâtir des solutions communes le
troisième sujet sur lequel nous avons
acté des éléments de convergence et
d'exigence
même si j'ai noté que dans son propos le
président est surtout revenu sur les
éléments de préoccupation et le
règlement du conflit russo ukrainien
je me rendrai demain à kiev
pour rencontrer le président zelensky et
nous sommes évidemment parfaite
coordination sur ce point avec le
chancelier olaf scholz avec lequel je me
suis étroitement coordonnées il ya
quelques jours et que je retrouverai
demain en fin d'après-midi à berlin
nous poursuivons nos efforts au sein du
format normandie en vue de la pleine
mise en oeuvre des accords de minsk et
d'une résolution durable du conflit dans
le donbass
la dernière réunion des conseillers
format normandie a permis d'acter le
soutien inconditionnel de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes au respect du
cessez-le-feu ce qui est une avancée
réelle et nous souhaitons bâtir sur
cette dynamique afin d'avancer de
manière très concrète et de continuer la
mise en oeuvre de ces accords
strictement et en totalité et nous
sommes revenus sur plusieurs points
techniques durant la discussion je veux
ici saluer les efforts faits par le
président zénith qui en particulier des
engagements clairs qu'il a pris dans ce
format et vis-à-vis de nous tous de
retirer les lois qu'ils n'étaient pas
conformes
justement aux accords de minsk puisque
les lois évoquée par le président
poutine ont bien été retirés à
l'initiative du président céline ce qui
de la même manière que le président
poutine a pu m'apporter plein de
clarifications sur les rumeurs qui
courent de loi qui serait ici déposée
qui ne serait pas non plus conforme à
ces accords il n'en serait pas du tout
question non plus sur la base de cette
situation qualifiée nous devons
continuer à avancer nous réengager c'est
essentiel pour la paix et la stabilité
en europe car ce conflit est au coeur
des tensions que nous vivons aujourd'hui
et il est nécessaire de parvenir à un
règlement qui permettrait que la russie
et l'union européenne puis serait
engagée fortement leurs relations
nous avons aussi évoqué plusieurs autres
sujets enfin
la question est évidemment conflit entre
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
et je veux aussi me féliciter de la
libération de huit réseaux lui
prisonniers qui est effectif depuis ce
matin transfert s'est fait
dans un avion mise à disposition par
notre centre de crise et qui fait suite
en effet à la visioconférence que nous
avons tenues avec le premier ministre à
chignon et le président aliyev vendredi
dernier et président aliyev a donc tenu
l'engagement pris à notre égard sur le
sujet des prisonniers des disparus de la
frontière des infrastructures de
connexion comme des éléments futur de
stabilité nous avons échangé de manière
très directe je crois pouvoir dire
d'ailleurs que nous avons une communauté
de vues président sur ce sujet et je
veux ici saluer en effet le rôle que vos
troupes ont pu avoir à la frontière dans
un temps qui est extrêmement difficile
et comme vous souligner l'importance
en effet
du comité de minsk dans le cadre
justement des accords qui sont
aujourd'hui les nôtres et donc du rôle
tout particulier que la russie et la
france joue à cet égard nous avons
également évoqué la question iranienne
suite aux initiatives prises récemment
par les états unis d'amérique et des
européens et là aussi une vraie
convergence de vues sur sur ce sujet
voilà je ne ferai pas plus long je veux
simplement dire que dans le moment
extrêmement grave que nous vivons pour
notre sécurité collective et la paix en
europe
nous avons pu mesurer les éléments
aujourd'hui
d'interprétations différentes ou de
désaccord relatif mais également les
éléments de convergence
notre devoir est de travailler ensemble
pour avancer
je crois pouvoir dire que nous sommes là
mais l'autre convaincu qu'il n'y a
aucune solution
raisonnable et durable qui ne passent
par le truchement les voies
diplomatiques et politiques
les prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines seront donc marquée par des
contacts que nous allons intensifier
avec évidemment
l'ensemble de nos partenaires européens
avec nos alliés avec également
le cren et les autres pays de la région
nous aurons l'occasion
dé d'ailleurs les prochains jours
devraient échanger ensemble par voie
téléphonique et sur le sujet de
l'ukraine comme de notre sécurité
collective notre volonté est de bâtir le
cadre de confiance qui nous permettra
d'avancer avec une même volonté
préserver la stabilité la paix et
réenclencher des mécanismes de confiance
pour notre europe c'est notre
responsabilité collective et je veux ici
dire l'engagement plein et entier de la
france en la matière je vous remercie
président pour votre accueil aujourd'hui
président yann doffin ainsi qu'un
journaliste soit pas
[Musique]
assez décevant comme en témoigne la
crise qui vous amène ici mais également
la présence au mali de mercenaires
russes qui attise un sentiment anti
français au point de remettre en cause
notre présence là bas votre action
monsieur le président at elle encore un
sens un effet et si oui lequel une
question ensuite pour monsieur le
président poutine une question simple
que tout le monde se pose monsieur le
président poutine comptez vous envahir
l'ukraine et si oui sous quelle forme et
sur le mali pouvez vous vous assurez les
yeux dans les yeux face au président
emmanuel macron que votre gouvernement
n'a rien à voir avec les mercian les
mercenaires sur place merci pour vos
réponses
sommairement ensuite concerne le mali le
président m'a posé plusieurs fois la
question nous en avons parlé en détail
mais monsieur le président on connaît
notre position le gouvernement russe n'a
rien à voir avec ces entreprises privées
qui travaillent au mali autant que je
sache le gouvernement il hume alliés n'a
fait aucune remarque sur la présence de
ces compagnies privées donc là il faut
s'en tenir à la logique générale qui
s'applique aussi à l'otan et aux membres
de l'organisation
si le mali a fait le choix de travailler
avec ces compagnies c'est son choix mais
je tiens à souligner et j'ajouterais
aussi quelque chose à monsieur le
président après la conférence de presse
l'état russe n'a rien à voir avec cela
il y a des intérêts commerciaux nos
compagnies privées s'entende avec le
gouvernement
nous suivons cela de façon plus intime
mais nous n'avons pas de lien avec sa
deuxième point à propos de la situation
en ukraine et à propos aussi de ceux
dont nous avons parlé de notre
préoccupation je les dis ici même à au
même endroit il ya quelques jours lors
de la conférence de presse que j'ai
donnée après non dialogue avec le
premier ministre hongrois
encore une fois je veux répéter cette
logique nous sommes catégoriquement
contre l'extension de l'otan avec
l'ajout de nouveaux membres à l'est
parce que cela constitue une menace
supplémentaire
d'extension à proximité de nos
frontières et ce n'est pas nous qui
bouge vers l'otan mais c'est l'otan qui
bouge vers nos soutiens donc encore une
fois quand on accuse la russie de 7 ans
c'est illogique
c'est pas nous qui nous approchons des
frontières c'est eux qui s'approche de
nos frontières ça s'apprend h l'autre
deuxièmement
pourquoi
est-ce dangereux d'admettre l'ukraine
regardez les pays européens y compris la
france trop ses nerfs que la crimée par
exemple fait partie de la grève mais
nous nous considérons que c'est une
partie de la fédération de russie ici
des tentatives sont entreprises pour
changer cette situation par la voie
militaire
alors que
ces doctrines allemand écrit dans les
documents
par le cren que la russie est
l'adversaire et que la crime et doit
recourir à la force militaire donc ce
cinquième article n'a pas été de l'otan
n'a pas été supprimée et wc récemment le
président biden a rappelé que l'article
5 aides important ça veut dire que donc
il y aura une confrontation militaire
entre l'otan et la russie est ce qu est
ce qu on va se battre avec eux l'otan
mais c'est la deuxième partie de la
question et vous voulez vous battre avec
la russie demandez à vos lecteurs
aux gens ont aussi demandé si les gens
veulent se battre avec la russie mais
posez leur la question est ce que c'est
ça que vous voulez donc notre
préoccupation est li dictée par le souci
de la sécurité européenne
en ce qui concerne l'eau de bath
les autorités
l'ukrainien disent qu'elles ne vont pas
respecter les accords de ministres
qu'ils le feront jamais parce que ça
casserait l'état la structure de détail
klein alors est-ce qu'ils vont respecter
ces accords ont passé une question alors
on parle des garanties de sécurité de
notre côté et qui va nous apporter des
garanties de sécurité déjà deux fois les
autorités ukrainiennes ont décidé de
résoudre la question de john bass par la
voie militaire
après les essais le premier essai y ait
eu les accords de minsk qui ont été
validés par le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu ils vont respecter ces accords
ou pas qu'est ce qu'on doit penser nous
ça deux fois déjà ils ont essayé
et qui garantit qu'il n'y aura pas de
troisième fois
donc tout ça ce sont des questions qui
ont besoin d'être étudiée en détail de
façon générale et je remercie le
président d'avoir permis justement que
nous discutions encore une fois de ces
questions ici à moscou ce sont des
questions de sécurité qui ne consomment
pas seulement la russie mais le monde
entier tout le nôtre nos propositions ne
parle pas seulement de l'extension de
l'otan mais aussi c'est le deuxième
point c'est le non déploiement d'armes
offensives à nos frontières alors si
tout le monde veut la paix et si tout le
monde veut la confiance qu'est ce qu'il
ya de mal ici ne pas déployer des armes
offensives à proximité de nos frontières
est ce que quelqu'un peut me dire en
quoi ces mauvais ou une si l'otan est
une organisation
pacifique qu'est ce qu'il y a de mal
alors à revenir à l'infrastructure
telle qu'elle était au moment de la
conclusion de l'accord de 1997 voilà
nous créons les conditions pour des
conditions de sécurité
donc encore une fois il ya des les
obligations sur la politique de la porte
ouverte coface a c'est aussi une
question cruciale pour nous et j'ai
expliqué pourquoi voilà nous avons parlé
de cela pendant presque et de moins
demain monsieur le président qui sera
inquiets et nous sommes mis d'accord il
a en tout cas exposé son plan et je me
suis très reconnaissant d'avoir fait
d'avoir consacré tant de temps à cela et
de chercher une solution qui puisse
satisfaire tout le monde
votre question
je pense habilités de la france
d'avoir une relation la plus forte
possible avec la russie
nous sommes de grands pays européens
et du concert des nations deux
puissances dotées membres du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies la relation
bilatérale est importante à la fois pour
que la relation se développe et que sur
les grands sujets internationaux on
puisse bâtir des solutions communes
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire sur
des questions comme la question
iranienne c'est des choses aussi sur
lesquels nous essayons de trouver des
votes convergence sur la question comme
la libye ou autre nous avons eu des
désaccords nous avons su bâtir parfois
des accords et des compromis donc pour
moi c'est une évidence
la deuxième chose c'est que
je crois que là-dessus nous nous
rejoindrons avec le président poutine la
russie et européennes
qui croit à l'europe doit savoir
travailler avec la russie et trouver les
voies et moyens de construire l'avenir
dans l'europe et avec les européens
est ce que ces choses et non mais est ce
que l'europe s'est faite sur des
initiatives aisés dont les résultats
étaient à effet immédiat non plus
donc est-ce que la tâche à une part
d'ingratitude
oui résolument
est ce que pour autant il convient de
l'abandonner
non
enfin je pense que la france parce que
c'est sa vocation parce qu'il se trouve
que c'est son rôle durant ce semestre
nous avons la présidence tournante du
conseil de l'union européenne ce site
porter la voix européenne
et de savoir
prendre en compte les termes d'une
discussion complexe avec un grand
voisins comme la russie qui est
déterminant pour notre sécurité
collective mais aussi
porté la voix et les contraintes et des
exigences de tous les pays européens
c'est ce que je me suis employé à faire
ces derniers jours par une concertation
étroite et en essayant ici d'être aussi
celui qui peut contribuer à chercher
cette voie il savait j'ai une conviction
simple si nous ne discutons pas avec la
russie est ce que nous accroissons notre
capacité collective à bâtir la paix non
acquis les sonos la place à d'autres
donc je pense que nous avons des
désaccords vous les avez constaté et
nous les assumons il ya des moments où
nous n'arrivons pas à faire avancer les
choses c'est ainsi et c'est le résultat
de ces désaccords je pense que nous
pouvons aussi à chaque étape
tâchez de bâtir des compromis en tout
cas je considère que c'est ma
responsabilité
aussi longtemps que ces compromis
préserve nos intérêts ceux de tous nos
partenaires et alliés
c'est la tâche qui est la nôtre et donc
les jours semaines qui viennent
nous met devant
cette tâche ardue
il va consister à inventer des solutions
nouvelles pour porter ces garanties tout
en respectant nos principes fondamentaux
et cette relation de voisinage notre
géographie ne changera pas
donc nous continuerons
comme cette agence
salle isidore
ndri calysto gaz et de connaissances
ma question pour le président russe
poutine comment évaluez-vous les
perspectives du règlement au sud est de
l'ukraine
à votre avis les accords de minsk sont
ils toujours en vie la président la
question pour le président français au
même sujet si je comprends bien vous
avez décidé de passer la nuit à moscou
c'est demain matin que vous allez vous
rendre à kiev ait
l'intention d'avoir géré monsieur
quel sera votre message pour qu'il faut
partager à qui m compte tenu des
déclarations récentes qui viennent de là
par exemple sur le fait que les accords
de musique s'y sont mises en oeuvre et
on sait que la france est un pays
garants jeu les accords de minsk je
trouve ça va détruire la surréalité
l'état l'état de l'ukraine en ce qui
concerne les accords de metz qui sont
toujours en vigueur ou pas est-ce qu'ils
ont une perspective simplement il n'ya
pas d'autre alternative c'est ce que je
considère je répète encore une fois
à kiev disent qu'ils vont respecter
après le disent qu'ils vont les détruire
parce que qu'ils vont pas les respecter
parce qu'ils vont détruire le pays le
président
ukrainien a dit récemment qu aucun des
points de l'accord ne met que ça plaise
ou non il faut respecter il n'y a pas
d'autre solution
s'ils veulent pas discuter directement
avec les représentants de d'albas mais
pourtant c'est écrit noir sur blanc
c'est le point numéro 12 le point 9 le
point 11 des accords de minsk et ils
doivent s'entendre avec les autorités de
ces territoires ils doivent valider ces
points là avec eux sinon comment ce
travail pour ce faire c'est pas possible
et donc ici il faut du courage
reconnaître ce qui est écrit
et ne pas détourner ce qui est écrit
noir sur blanc est donc le les autorités
actuelles ont remporté les élections les
élections sur le fait qu'ils allaient
remporter
pacifiquement cette bataille et j'espère
que enfin cela va être serré qu'il ya
une prise de conscience
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre solution
toujours encore une fois semaine
prochaine qu il est accusé de trahison
nationale
ont fait à l'aise en fait qu'il a si
lille a signé sa part oui les assonais
et alors tout le pays l'a accepté à
l'époque ça a été confirmé par une
résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu
et je n'ai pas présenté quand je dis que
le temps viendra où nous ne serons prêts
à le fournir
l'asile politique
pour des conditions pour des raisons
humanitaires
humanitaire c'est ce que j'ai dit
voilà c'est ce que j'avais dit et c'est
ce qui se passe et maintenant il fait
l'objet de poursuites
donc tout cela c'est des choses qui
concerne la lutte interne
et je propose de s'élever au dessus de
cela et de considérer les choses dans
une perspective historique stratégique
pour l'ukraine elle même travaillé à sa
coopération avec la russie dans des
conscient de stabilité et de paix pour
tout le monde pour tous les acteurs de
la scène internationale
la première chose
le présidence de nice qui est le
président d'un pays aux frontières
desquels il ya 125 mille soldats russes
donc
oserais-je dire ça rend nerveux
et c'est un seul nouveau de ces derniers
mois ce n'était pas tout à fait la
réalité au début de l'année 2000 21 donc
je veux ici saluer malgré tout puisque
vous avez ici l'esprit de citer une
remarque récente je trouve que dans le
concert des commentaires politiques
internationaux le président est dit qui
fait pas fait partie de celles et ceux
qui ont un grand sang froid qu'il faut
saluer la deuxième chose c'est que quand
les accords de minsk ont été signés il
n'y avait pas cette intensité de
présence militaire russe hors frontières
mais c'est aussi pour ça que c'est pour
nous un élément le changement profond il
faudrait pas que ça vienne dénaturer les
discussions les brouilles et ça fait
partie des discussions que nous avons
eues avec le président poutine et quand
je parle de stabilité puis de
désescalade c'est bien de cela dont il
s'agit ils saisissent de la frontière
russe bellos
ensuite de manière très claire
la solution à la crise ukrainienne ne
peut être que politique et les bases ne
sont que les accords de minsk et le bon
format le format normandie où je vous le
rappelle il ya autour de la table
l'ukraine la russie la france
l'allemagne
ces accords prévoient une série
d'initiatives et de progrès ils sont à
conduire dans les prochains jours et les
prochaines semaines c'est sur cette base
là que nos conseillers se sont réunis et
a maintenant une dizaine de jours à
paris pour la première fois depuis de
longs mois un communiqué conjoint et une
reprise du processus il ya des
discussions très sensible sur les
questions de statut d'élections
modification constitutionnelle qui sont
en cours et qui connaîtront de nouveaux
développements dans les heures et les
jours qui viennent c'est dans ce cadre
là que nous pourrons avancer
j'ai eu à plusieurs reprises le
président est né ce qui avant de venir
j'ai pu le dire au président poutine
lors de notre échange c'est bien les
accords de minsk qui seuls peuvent
prévaloir au règlement de la crise du
conflit russo ukrainien à ces avancées
et le format normandie qui
l'accompagnent c'est ainsi que nous
entendons avancer et c'est sur cette
base que j'aurais demain des échanges
avec le président céline ski
une question de valérie gas radio france
internationale
bonsoir messieurs les présidents
monsieur président macro avec quelle
casquette êtes vous venu à moscou
aujourd'hui parler vous au nom de la
france ou de tous les européens le
chancelier schulz est actuellement à
washington n'aurait-il pas mieux valu à
venir à 2 comme l'avait fait françois
hollande et angela merkel en 2015 pour
montrer l'unité de l'europe monsieur le
président poutine emmanuel macron est il
pour vous le seul interlocuteur en
europe vous avez dit qu'il était un
interlocuteur de qualité ou le
considérez vous comme un intermédiaire
pour faire passer des messages à tous
les européens et monsieur macron si on
pouvait aussi nous donner la réponse sur
la force wagner qui a été évoqué tout à
l'heure est votre avis sur l'implication
de l'état russe merci
de vos
attaques et aux mimiques à coggia russe
n'a pleuré ce schéma
initial sans arrière pensée
un accord a été conclu entre les
autorités maliennes et
les compagnies privées ils sont
satisfaits du travail l'état russe ici
n'y est pour rien en ce qui concerne la
première partie de votre question
encore une fois je voudrais souligner
cela je les dis
mais je voudrais bien que vous
n'entendiez
pensez aussi à ceux qui vont vous lire
est ce que vous comprenez ou pas que si
le crâne fait partie de l'otan et deux
façons militaire va reprendre la crimée
les pays européens sont automatiquement
impliqué dans un combat milite dans un
conflit militaire avec la russie on
comprend bien ça et on sait bien que la
russie est une des zones une des
puissances nucléaires ici et que sur ce
plan elle dépasse beaucoup de ses
concurrents et il n'y aura pas de guérir
en 2g de gagnant dans ce dans ce conflit
vous auriez même pas le temps de cligner
des yeux et voilà le président ne veut
pas non plus cette évolution et moi non
plus je ne veux pas je ne le veux pas
et c'est pour ça que il est ici présents
et que depuis 6 heures il me torture
avec ces questions avec ses propositions
de solutions mais je considère que c'est
une mission tout à fait de nobles et je
lui suis grave
je le remercie d'avoir entreprises c'est
démarches pour trouver un compromis
et de considérer les propositions que
nous avons envoyé à washington à l'otan
aucun des points que nous considérons
comme non exécutables
il ya des questions courantes pendant
sur la situation dans le dans de basses
la russie le président l'a dit la russie
organise des exercices militaires etc
il ya ces 120 mille hommes qui sont
concentrés c'est donc de ne pas séparer
donc deux fois ils ont aussi
militairement de le faire dans le
donbass ils ne l'ont pas caché
d'ailleurs ils ont utilisé matériel
militaire l'aviation militaire
et qui va nous donner des garanties que
ce sera pas une agression contre nos
donc cela ne nous préoccupe donc tout
cela est complexe c'est un ensemble 2.1
qui sont intriqués les avec les autres
mais j'espère que demain monsieur le
président et je comprends bien que ce ne
sera pas facile ce sont des questions
difficiles mais nous sommes mis d'accord
sur le fait qu'après les autorités ces
consultations avec les autorités
ukrainiennes il me donnera un retour sur
ce que les autorités ukrainiennes
considère comme acceptable aujourd'hui
ou pas comment on peut continuer à
discuter comment on peut avancer
que j'ai été visitées
ya quinze jours pardon et avec lequel
j'ai changé à plusieurs reprises depuis
et nous aurons une coordination dès
notre retour et
de washington et de moscou de la même
manière qu'en tant que président du
conseil de l'union européenne pour ce
semestre j'ai pu échanger avec
l'ensemble
des mes collègues qui sont les plus
exposés à cette situation et qui sont
des préoccupations ou des voix forte sur
ce sujet ces derniers jours ont été
d'ailleurs marqué par toutes ces
consultations y compris d'ailleurs avec
britanniques et américains à deux
reprises donc les consultations sont
extrêmement intenses le chancelier lui
viendra la semaine prochaine parce que
ce que je fais aujourd'hui est très
différent des situations que nous avons
pu connaître et en 2008 et en 2014 nous
ne sommes pas dans une situation de
guerre chaude
comme il ya eu en géorgie en ukraine
nous sommes dans une situation de
tension extrême à un niveau
d'incandescence que l'europe a rarement
connu ces dernières décennies dont vous
avez compris c'était essentiellement un
sujet entre russie et otan et au fond
sur notre sécurité collective c'est donc
un processus que nous entamons
mais c'est profondément différent des
situations auxquelles vous faites
référence
c'est pourquoi nous allons continuer
d'abord cette concertation très étroite
mais sur la base de les changes que nous
avons eu aujourd'hui dans aussi avancé
essayez d'enclencher un mécanisme
nouveau
la situation nouvelle réponse
forcément différente
sur wagner la réponse du président est
claire la france ne connaît que les
états et la lutte contre le terrorisme
et donc
nous prenons nos décisions
au regard de nos relations avec des
états souverains avec un agenda qui est
la lutte contre le terrorisme et en
étroite coordination avec la région en
espérant en espace en espèces la cedeao
et l'union africaine c'est ce que nous
continuons de concerter ce sur quoi nous
tranchons
investi les locaux
mais ce n'est pas ce que
nous avons semé l'émoi et
impression générale qu'après la
situation où le teint
le gauchito ont répondu à cette question
sur
cette question et reste
sous silence chez makro à votre avis
pour les européens les garanties à la
russie c'est un sujet fermé et voyez
vous des moyens de résoudre ce problème
c'est possible je voudrais préciser il a
réussi a eu la réponse qu'elle l'ait
vous faire ensuite
je voudrais aussi revenir à vos paroles
vous avez dit l'un des arguments de nos
partenaires concernant l'alliance
le caractère pacifique de l'alliance je
vous rappelle que ce n'est pas une
organisation militaire don mello vision
politique et un autre argument selon
lequel les décisions sont prises par le
consensus au sein de l'otan si un homme
bon nombre de pays membres sont contre
l'adhésion de l'ukraine qui n'aura pas
lieu que pourriez-vous dire de vos
préoccupations là dessus
en ce qui concerne le caractère
militaire ou non militaire de cette
organisation je l' ai déjà dit ici il ya
le bombardement de belgrade
l'irak
la syrie l'afghanistan et cetera comment
ce n'est pas mon militaire mais si c'est
complètement militaires
à propos de
le fait que certains pays peuvent être
contre
l'adhésion de l'ukraine et de la géorgie
dans
l'organisation nous le savons nous
l'avons entendu souvent et donc j'ai une
question si c'est comme ça pourquoi ces
pays en 2008 ont signé à buter reste un
document qui fait que les portes sont
ouvertes à ces pays au sein de
l'organisation et même de manière
générale ça fait 30 ans que nous
cherchons à convaincre de ne pas faire
telle chose première chose deuxième
chose troisième chose
et nos préoccupations sont complètement
ignorées passer sous silence oui
monsieur le président en cours de notre
discussion
il va pas être fâché que - et aidez vous
même vous avez enfreint la
l'un
l'intégrité territoriale
donc le but en 75 l'acte final qui avait
été adoptée en 2010 hervé l'acte
d'astana c'est à dire que la sécurité
d'un pays ne doit pas se faire aux
défauts défendre ce dépendre de l'autre
sécurité d'annoter c'est pas tout à fait
comme ça est ce que
est ce que nous avons fait d'autres
opérations en 2014 en crimée nous
n'avons jamais jamais fait ça dans aucun
pays nous n'avions même pas en tête ce
lieu est pourquoi les pays occidentaux
ont soutenu ce coup d'état le la source
du pouvoir en ukraine c'est un coup
d'état depuis ce moment là et n'ont pas
la volonté du peuple oui ensuite il ya
eu des élections des élections mais à
l'origine
ce pouvoir est issu d'un coup de force
du sang a coulé et par conséquent dans
ces conditions nous étions obligés de
défendre les personnes qui en crimée
vivent sur place
et ont fait appel à nous pourquoi vous
les a mis dans cette situation
en 2014 des représentants de plusieurs
pays des pays européens sont venus
apposé leur signature en tant que pays
garants pour le processus trois jours
après par la force le pouvoir a été
confiée ils ne respectent rien et nous
demande de respecter les accords écoutez
ça marche pas comme ça ça ce jeu dans
bac à sable ça ne nous plaît pas
si vous êtes d'accord il y a ce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui à partir de là il faut
trouver une solution il faut chercher et
c'est ce que nous avons fait pendant
plusieurs et nous avons l'intention de
poursuivre poursuivre ce travail qu'est
ce que nous allons faire plus tard là
nous allons
préparer une réponse ou aux documents
que nous avons reçus de bruxelles et de
washington j'ai informé dans les grandes
lignes le président nous allons envoyer
cette réponse à washington et à
bruxelles effectivement des points qu'on
peut discuter ils sont
secondaires mais en tout cas on peut en
parler sur les questions cruciales nous
n'avons pas de réponse mais sur les
réponses que nous avons reçues
nos partenaires nous demande de ne pas
publier leurs réponses c'est
reconnaissez les reconnaissait de c'est
un peu curieux comme des pages on voit
pourquoi pourquoi ils veulent pas
l'exposer mais je ne vais pas
révéler chaque point mais sur les points
clés
c'est à dire la non extension de l'étang
le non déploiement d'armes offensives à
nos frontières et le retour au statu quo
de 1997
il ya ces différents points il ya même
pas de réponse à ça non oui ou non
comme si nous n'avions même pas posé ces
questions et qui ils sont contournées
tout le reste il ya quelques clichés
politique et des propositions sur des
points qui sont secondaires
je ne considère pas que le dialogue est
terminée nous allons formuler
rédiger des réponses nous allons les
envoyer à washington à bruxelles le
président a été informé de la teneur de
notre position
est la lecture des dernières décennies
qui n'est pas aujourd'hui partagée entre
les alliés de l'otan et la russie c'est
un état de fait
parce que cette charte qu'on évoque
depuis tout à l'heure cette charte de
paris texte de loi met aussi très
clairement noir sur blanc le respect de
la souveraineté de l'intégrité
territoriale des droits de l'homme des
principes qui ont aussi été violée par
l'otan
donc la situation est là et il est
évident que ni l'otan ni les états unis
d'amérique ne vont donner droit à toutes
les demandes qui ont été faites par la
russie dans un contexte de très forte
pression militaire comme je l'évoquais
tout à l'heure aux frontières de
l'ukraine et avec chaque jour des
nouvelles qui sortent sans dire qu'une
attaque va être lancé
j'ai entendu les propos du président sa
volonté d'avancer
sur un règlement politique
mais la situation est là celle d'une
grande tension
donc trouver un accord et construire une
solution politique ça ne veut pas dire
on est d'accord sur tout circuler
mais un processus qui a été entamée
est ce que les échanges de lettres est
un processus qui permet sur des sujets
aussi complexes
de régler les choses je pense qu'il
trouvera un moment donné ses limites
est-ce que la seule question de l'otan
permet de régler tout je ne crois pas
non plus elle est essentielle
je pense qu'il ya d'autres sujets de son
pour battre pour bâtir notre know
garantir une sécurité collective ça a
été le fruit de nos discussions
d'aujourd'hui est donc ma conviction
c'est ce pourquoi je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est que nous avons besoin d'un
réengagement collectif celui de la
russie celui des etats-unis d'amérique
dont je me félicite celui des européens
et de l'ensemble des alliés pour
concrètement d'abord essayé au maximum
de lever les malentendus du passé
parce qu'il y en a de revenir sur nos
traumatismes qui ne sont aujourd'hui en
train de de revenir et de créer au fond
des lectures complètement orthogonale de
ce qu'est l'europe des 30 dernières
années mais surtout de bâtir des
solutions utiles donc moi la priorité si
je peux être très clair avec vous c'est
la stabilité de la situation sur le plan
militaire à court terme qu'il n'y aucune
provocation ou escalade c'est le
principal objet de ma visite ici et
demain actifs sur cette base c'est que
le dialogue qui a été noué avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
autant états unis d'amérique européen se
poursuivent pour bâtir au fond des
solutions de court et de moyen terme
avec quel objectif
la sécurité de tous il n'y a pas de
sécurité pour les européens s'il n'y a
pas de sécurité pour l'artiste mais ce
que j'entends là c'est ce que j'ai
entendu hier en parlant à mes collègues
en lettonie et en estonie en lituanie en
pologne ou ailleurs ils ont les mêmes
craintes ils ont le sentiment aussi que
les mêmes accords avaient été violés
qu'on leur avait promis qu'il n'y aurait
pas de déploiement qui a eu des
déploiements donc il nous faut des
processus de transparence de désescalade
il nous faut rebâtir ses solutions
concrètes ensemble parce que nous vivons
de part et d'autre de frontière commune
et partagée
et donc les prochaines semaines doivent
être consacrés à cela et en même temps
aussi à notre capacité à bâtir cette
sécurité en respectant pleinement la
souveraineté et l'indépendance
de plusieurs états qui ne sont pas
membres de l'union européenne ou de
l'otan mais qui sont pour autant dans la
région pensent à la biélorussie je pense
à l'ukraine évidemment je pense à la
géorgie je pense à la moldavie qui sont
des états dont l'indépendance la
souveraineté doit être aussi pleinement
respectée car celle ci participe de
notre sécurité collective et donc il
faut bâtir les termes de celle ci sur
l'ukraine on en connaît le cadre ce sont
les accords de minsk et le processus de
normandie mais surtout le reste il faut
avoir un débat extrêmement franc et
transparent
stabilité
création des conditions de confiance
pour aller vers une désescalade ce qui
suppose de construire les termes nouveau
sur la base de nos valeurs et de ce que
nous avons acté à 30 ans mais
en regardant aujourd'hui nos désaccords
et la situation mais bâtir des solutions
nouvelle tous ensemble pour cette
sécurité cette stabilité collectif nous
avons esquissé quelques pistes dans
notre tête à tête avec le président
poutine je vais m'employer
essayer de tirer celle ci je sais que
lui aussi s'emploiera à travers les
réponses qui fera à l'otan aux etats
unis d'amérique à
poursuivre ses propres solutions mais
par l'intensification de ces dialogues
le fait que nous nous reparlerons dans
quelques jours que nous apprécierons
d'ailleurs des nouvelles initiatives à
prendre
ensemble et avec toutes les parties
prenantes considéré je suis sûr que nous
arriverons à un résultat il n'est pas
aisé mais j'en suis sûr
sais pas si beaucoup de guides merci
merci beaucoup
je vais pas non